the Afghan girls and women are bearing
the biggest burden in this struggle to
persuade people that girls and women
have an equal right to education and to
other amenities women and girls not
going to school not going to University
not able to teach at University not
doing public sector jobs being banned
from many subjects that are taught
already and of course what it means is
that they are denied opportunity it does
seem to be the misreading of Islamic
teaching by a group of clerics based in
Kandahar
and the way that we can uh deal with
this is for all our leaders in Muslim
countries
uh to protest and to say Islamic nor
does not require this we do educate our
girls and and women and we're not going
to work with an Afghanistan that fails
to provide equal opportunities for girls
and women in the future you've already
seen statements from the Saudi foreign
Ministry
from qatar's foreign Ministry and they
are intermediaries between us and uh and
and the Taliban that have done very well
in doing that on many occasions but
they're saying end this ban and so to a
UAE I think this is going to be solved
by uh people within the Muslim world uh
pressing the Afghans to persuade them
that it is counterproductive in the long
run to deny girls and women education uh
they're making their economy unworkable
in future years if they can't train the
engineers the scientists the doctors and
the teachers